[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a chinese youth romance
film called sweet combat spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
in the opening scene we are introduced
to fang yoo the best female mma fighter
in the state she has only recently
started taking part in official matches
but has had an unbeatable record her
recent big win has caused a sensation in
the media making her even more popular a
flashback shows us fang yoo telling her
wealthy businessman grandfather that she
wants to be a fighter she was always
expected to help the family business
growing up hence her grandfather was
very disappointed
then we are introduced to ming tian a
young man living in macau he has two
younger siblings currently studying in
middle school the kids are ming tion's
responsibility since their mother
abandoned them and their father passed
away his brother loves watching mma
fights on tv and his favorite fighter is
fang yoo who he refers to as the queen
to earn for his younger siblings ming
tian had to drop out of college and
start working as a delivery guy at a
local restaurant currently he is trying
his best to get into a college with a
decent scholarship to continue his
education one day at work he is asked to
deliver food to a local martial arts
teacher the job is difficult because the
place is 20 minutes away but the
receiver wants the food in less than 15.
during the time of pressure we get to
see ming tian's great sense of direction
he has basically memorized every street
and shortcut in the city which helps him
do his job efficiently when almost at
the destination he sees a poor street
vendor trying to collect fruits that
have fallen from her cart as he helps
her the cart runs down the street this
is when the mma fighter fangio appears
in the scene and kicks the cart to stop
it from moving further it does more
damage than good as the cart breaks and
all the fruits are destroyed when asked
to apologize to the vendor she simply
hands her a bundle of money for the
damage and walks away mingtian huffs at
the rude girl and continues his way to
make the delivery fangio then goes to
her former martial arts teacher and asks
him for help she is being pressured by
her family to leave mma and join their
business confused she wants him to make
the decision for her but the teacher
refuses to do it as the decision is hers
and hers alone to make just then
mingtian arrives revealing that the
customer who ordered the food is also
the martial arts teacher he and feng yu
look at each other but do not share a
word before going their separate ways on
his way to the restaurant ming tian gets
an email from a college offering to
provide him a 70 scholarship however the
college is in another state he is
confused if he should move for his
education or stay because his siblings
are already accustomed to their life in
macau to solve the dilemma he goes to a
wisdom fountain and asks the universe to
show him the way at the same time fang
you is on the other side of the fountain
doing the same they think for a while
and come to a decision fang yoo decides
to go through with her fighting career
while ming tian plans to move to another
state mingtyon's boss is a kind man who
helps him with the moving process and
provides him a job as a delivery guy in
the place he is moving to he even offers
ming tian money and resources if he
needs them in the following scene we see
ming tion and his siblings move into a
new house although it is not the best
neighborhood the interior of the place
is quite homely the kids seem to love it
which ultimately makes ming tian happy
as the first piece of decoration he puts
a picture of him and his master on a
shelf it is revealed that he used to
train in boxing with the master before
his death following that ming tion takes
the kids to school signs into his new
job at a kfc then finally goes to the
college for the first time he has been
enrolled in the best sports college in
the state zhang zee before this year the
college was all girls in fact ming tion
will be one of the first guys to go to
zhang zee however when he walks in he
realizes he might be the only guy among
hundreds of girls at the college he
starts to wonder if he misread the offer
letter because not a single man is in
sight the girls are intrigued by the
only man and it doesn't help that he is
also very handsome suddenly he bumps
into xiaomi a tomboyish student who
loves to box and skate ming tion
mistakes her for a guy and instantly
starts chatting about how grateful he is
to find another male instead of
correcting him xiaomi simply puts a tiny
pink clip on her hair and introduces
herself a shocked ming tion apologizes
before she skates away while glaring at
him the president and a teacher named mr
wang are worried because initially 10
men had applied to the college but after
taking a tour and seeing only girls all
of them requested a transfer currently
ming tion is the only one left the
president orders mr wang to do whatever
it takes to keep him content so he won't
leave they want to expand the college's
horizons and the presence of male
students will take a huge part in that
outside the girls start going crazy
because of ming tian they block his way
offering help that he clearly doesn't
need one of the girls and xiaomi get
into an argument regarding who gets to
take mingtyon to the principal's office
the conflict only ends when he tricks
them into looking the other way and runs
away while he is at it he happens to
bump into feng yu he instantly
recognizes her as the rude girl from
macau she accidentally cuts his hand
with her bag and gives him money to
apply a band-aid to it ming tian is
furious at her materialistic behavior he
demands an apology but to fang you money
is superior to an apology before leaving
ming tion calls her a mannerless freak
which triggers a childhood trauma in
feng yu a flashback shows us that feng
yu kicked the cart that day to save a
little girl crossing the road in front
of them her intentions were pure but it
caused the street vendor to suffer a
loss in class ming tion sits among
several girls and is clearly
uncomfortable the girls cannot help but
stare at him even though he doesn't
fancy the attention meanwhile xiaomi and
fang yoo are training together in the
college's boxing club it is revealed
that they are best friends who share a
common interest in boxing xiaomi sees
that something is bothering fang you on
being asked fang yu claims that the new
guy's harsh comments made her rethink
her behavior in the following scene she
is at home thinking about ming tion yet
again a flashback shows us that when she
was little her parents refused to
acknowledge that she was a girl they
always wanted a son so when she was born
they treated her like one she wasn't
allowed to grow her hair or wear girly
clothes her naive mind only understood
that she was a girl when her younger
brother was born only after his birth
did her parents allow her to wear
dresses overjoyed at finally being able
to express herself she went to her crush
and gave him a gift but since all her
friends thought she was a boy they
called her a freak the incident bothered
her so much that she still struggles
with her gender identity meanwhile at
ming tion's home his brother wakes up in
his sleep and throws punches in the air
ming tion laughs at his cuteness before
realizing that the girl he argued with
is his brother's idol he thinks to
himself that fangio's eyes resemble his
mother's eyes which made him angrier
than he should have been earlier that
day in college ming tian is continuously
bothered by the girls so much so that he
can hardly concentrate on studying the
president and mr wang on the other hand
are overjoyed that he agreed to stay but
ming tian is planning to transfer to
another college even though they provide
less percentage of tuition scholarship
the college's diverse clubs are the
distinguishing feature unique to it the
students spend more time in the clubs
comparatively than their studies
in the clubs their talent and skills are
polished and showcased at an
international level some girls take
boxing some take taekwondo some
gymnastics and so on feng yu and xiaomi
are in the boxing club the freshmen are
encouraged to take a tour of all the
clubs to choose one that they would like
to join during the tour ming tion checks
out the boxing club and finds xiaomi and
feng yu fighting he is mesmerized by
feng yu's skills that are very similar
to his masters he assumes that she must
have trained with the same master but
dismisses the thought the girls force
ming tion to be in their clubs and even
fight each other for the same reason to
get rid of them ming tion disregards his
interests and decides to join the
swimming club the one with the fewest
members he confidently goes to the pool
and takes a dive waiting for the
instructors to arrive but strangely
enough the pool is filled with several
fish a woman informs him that the club
has been disbanded due to low enrollment
and the swimming pool has been modified
into an ecological pool this is the last
straw for ming tion he decides to
transfer to another college even if it
means paying more tuition fees he brings
his concern to mr wang who begs him to
stay he even takes a picture of ming
tion to put its silhouette in front of
the men's bathroom being constructed
down the hall but the honor isn't enough
to make ming tion stay when he
repeatedly requests mr wang reveals that
the transferring process is quite easy
he will have to fill out a form and post
it to the college's filing box ming tian
does as told but is faced with a slight
problem when he goes to post the form a
group of women who claim to be the first
graduates of the college stops him they
have been unofficially appointed by the
president to stop ming tian from getting
to the filing box the trained women
easily defeat him and send him back to
mr wang's office the teacher refuses to
let ming tien transfer but offers him a
more appealing deal he promises to
extend his student loan payment period
to 30 years with zero interest ming tion
will be studying for free if he takes
the deal with his current financial
condition he doesn't want to miss such
an opportunity still the pressure of
being the only guy among hundreds of
girls is too much for him he decides to
consider the idea later ming tian goes
to a bathroom to change but it turns out
to be women's he bumps into a naked feng
yoo who kicks him to the ground as the
two argue xiaomi barges in and assumes
they were doing something fishy the two
dismiss her performing tion walks away
in the following scene we see xiaomi
thangyu and their rival from the
taekwondo class at an ice cream parlor
arguing about who gets the last scoop of
the strawberry flavor meanwhile ming
tion is on his way to deliver food when
he notices a bully dragging a kid across
the street he helps the kid run away but
is in turn caught by the bullies they
take him to a field and threaten him
until the girls arrive on the scene
initially they try to solve the problem
by talking but when the bullies start
getting handsy they get into a fight
after a long and entertaining struggle
the girls and ming tion managed to chase
them away ming tion is beyond grateful
to them and befriends them after the
incident because of the girls college
life doesn't seem that bad to him even
though he might face problems on the way
he decides to terminate his transfer and
stay at zhang zee the very next day he
accepts mr wang's offer much to the
teacher's delight with his new friends
and added advantages ming tion hopes to
have a smooth college life for the next
four years
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching